[Musique]
on
et bonsoir bienvenue au piano zag
bon je suis un dingue
je suis drogué et qu'elle se croquer
c'est un petit bassin
paraît le plus génial qu'un mari
oui je suis dingue dingue de l'astag
je suis marteau toto ne se disent trop
passionnelles moi la musique est
inaudible d'écossé après nos sites et
les vieux c'est l'abus
j'avais de 10 génie de tableau et
soprano
on salive ne rêvez pas d'internet là
précisément tous au piano le violon
dingue c'est le royaume des projecteurs
c'est l'escalier les auteurs du lot
c'est en regardant sa qualité
impressionnante tout mcaleese à vouzan
pénétrer le coeur d'alêne espoir pour
jeu très direct chansons de se faire
justice aux hommes de sex-symbol
on trouve parmi les décideurs du music
hall ou à défaut d'augmenter sa vie de
garçon
je ne prolongerai au micro tatarata
sinatra moi je suis bien l'auteur
je suis ok seth rogen c'est là
le plus génial et cabaye
oui je suis d'accord
je suis content de ce bistro bar à
cocktails à la musique
ces téléviseurs
[Applaudissements]
le petit j'ai vu le chrono mais s'offre
à nos candidats
masi simon de vous au piano
comme certains soir à tournon comme les
bio
amy anti déprime et par l'osce
ne sachant plus vers quel endroit à
porter tes fesses pour vivre
ton studio perds pas ton temps à théoule
et sur les réseaux est un peu dessus
peut déterminer pour effacer
[Musique]
royal comme une autre de bruit et ça
aux as tu sanogo ce troquet c'est génial
tu seras un clin d'oeil sur la vague
tussauds apporte autant de ce glissement
à craquer la musique djibo
concert pour être cité
10 gbe les caboulots les sopranos
consolide
si si
tous aux biens
petit rodez petite ava midi libre
est-ce que la première
j'ai la peau
gentil côtoieront
c'est pas le pied au gris hu
alors un petit medley à l'exemple de la
brune aurait pu coûter chose un petit
mètre un petit medley on peut faire les
garçons lechner voilà le fait m est-ce
qu'on peut tous rentrés dans leur
contrée corner passe experts
on voit pas trop sage c'est un but ça
fait quand même saluer un choc tous les
soirs tu peux enfin des ports et
jean-philippe souffrance eh oui tous les
soirs alors vous fermer nos âmes et les
quelque chose de non lieu un sujet qu'on
aime bien
oui nous échec de wilshere il coûte cher
surtout dans les messieurs les garçons
sous toutes les coutures
enfin aujourd'hui son coup tu me
[Musique]
manqueras pas voilà ce qu'il ya de
meilleur au monde
oui car un bon copain sébile à la main
à
chaque seconde henri de ses chagrins
camp d'opposants à joe cobra
attention les gars comme le
tuchan chance cochés on est super
contents de moi je serai toujours là je
vais bien je ne sais quoi je marchais
dans la nuit je charge a tout oublié
mais c'est plus fort que moi je ne peut
désirer
j'étais malade je n'ai pas un moment
je n'oublierai jamais nous donc ramasser
mais toutes les nuits tous les jours
[Musique]
la belle histoire d'amour
je suis
[Musique]
m
jal est tellement dans la peau j'en suis
marteau d'hakim approche ça finit je
suis à lui causer yeux sur la soupe aux
autres
oh
rosa
c'est pas en son nom je sais
[Musique]
il m'avait toute la nuit pour les
lyonnais
[Applaudissements]
j'ai quitté le tuba et les sens avant
dans le matin de 1
comment vit-on
grit est pas il sentait bon le sable
chaud
bon les violets
retournez à marne-la-vallée tant besoin
de toi besson désiré
joue
troublant c'est en tout genre
celle là
pour y mourir enchantée
[Musique]
johnny qui n'est pas un enjeu
ne craint pas que ça me dérange
j'aurais dit je pense à toi toi tu te
souviens de mozart en jeu et quand elle
me pique envers jeu mais johnny tu n'es
pas sage que je t'aime que je t'aime que
je t'aime
ak je t'aime
je t'aime que je t'aime quand on vous
soigne tous les mini tas de akwa droit
de l'ohada tu te pleure pas laisser
tomber tant pis
[Musique]
nouveau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cuba et bibelots tabac
pour les uns télécharge le mérite or
avec mes yeux pour l'instant les
solutionner les ans
il est important
à
je continue comme ça c'est que l'album
de souvenirs j'en ai quand même un bon
jour une nouvelle demande - tous les
vols dans la conquête française en plein
territoire ennemi d'internet
[Musique]
les bras
cuba
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
linars dit tu es abonné vous y mettez un
peu de bleu